previously on TV since fatter sir they
called me Terry titties and that's the
truth with some cheese on it ain't no
meat loaf between these bars boss I know
we are rightfully focused on the
brilliant conversation on the bench but
I've become convinced the park behind
them is a portal to another dimension
the couples walk from right to left here
and aren't seen again until walking the
same direction a minute later then they
teleport from here to here with no
explanation
also this pillar seems to be the heart
of the anomaly is this dog walker and
bicyclists disappear behind never to
return
look all I'm saying is that if Stephen
King hasn't written a novel about this
park by next Tuesday someone should
check and see if he's still breathing
you know you should do it's a garbage
truck except that the only thing
stranger than a perk garbage truck on a
street is to park garbage trucks on the
same street line I think we're supposed
to think Badgers being smart here but
really is a garbage idea if you ask a
cop if he's a cop he's like obligated to
tell you it's in the Constitution
oh come on how does badger get to be
smart enough to sniff out this boss down
to pointing out the exact vans and still
dumb enough to fall for this nonsense
he could be clever and keenly aware or
clueless and gullible but both is a hard
set this is a crafty hiding place but
not a functional one I was badger
controlling the people walking by and
what they are throwing into the trash
can by the end of his drug-dealing shift
that bag would be soaked in so many
different liquids no one would want to
touch it and the trash gets picked up
every now and then right so what does he
do on the days that the trashcan is
empty or only half-full I love DJ Qualls
you up DJ Qualls but the show holds
speed up by DJ Qualls as a cop and there
is no amount of undercover that would
make that believable so here's a sin for
Breaking Bad casting I had a good job
until my boss accused me of stealing
roll commercials
wait this actually is a commercial that
says the episode title and also the
spin-off title on a screen inside our
screen inside your screen
this is like the sitting section of role
commercials it's time going faster here
has anyone seen my sim totem I need a
big kick also commercial or TV show
within a TV show is so over the top and
ridiculous that it takes you out of the
moment cliche yeah I really need to get
some furniture I suggest a bed look our
founders declared once you decide floor
can commence then you have lost said
rights to later request more comfortable
alternatives it's in the Constitution of
America oh I love these two together
excited to see the relationship blossom
and the beautiful things that are
certainly in store I'm honestly choking
up a bit right now who sleeps with a
watch like this on I don't even
understand how people sleep with those
fitness trackers on I flail about so
much at night that if I slept with a
watch on my face in the morning would
look like Edward Scissorhands try to
apply his own guyliner
really because last I checked the only
thing plugged into that TV was the power
cord so unless DirecTV is installing
their boxes in the wall directly behind
the TVs 10 years ago on called if
mannequins it's kind of cool how every
name has a chemical element highlighted
in the letters except that CH isn't
actually a defined chemical symbol maybe
you thought it was chlorine but that's
CL show doesn't know how to periodic
table correctly eating out food with
mayonnaise in it for more than 30
seconds is a second for about an hour
and could put an Oscar he's so damn
crazy in this case it would be an Emmy
and seems like as good a time as any to
send the fact that neither Dean Norris
or Betsy Brandt ever got even nominated
for an Emmy for their work on this show
he's gonna show me like crap through a
tin [ __ ]
crap through a tin horn I guess you
heard about what happened down Maura's
like Apocalypse Now down there Colonel
Kurtz holed up in his jungle and dudes
are showing up 60 pounds overweight
typhoon Olga's washing out all the sets
and Martin Sheen had a freaking heart
attack
I deal with you and we don't have much
of what you might call an experience all
overlap obvious irony is obvious aside
when would Hank ever use a word like
experiential just show okay count your
money isn't that what the machine behind
him that counts money is for ya don't
you cover for [ __ ] I ask you a
straight-up question I expect a
straight-up answer then maybe leave the
phony rear
so you can hear said answer what are you
doing talking to my client without me
present you sneaky beat since we find
out in a second that Saul Goodman can't
keep his clients in cases straight I'm
guessing he also can't recall which show
he's on all the time and is wondering
where Giovanni Ribisi is make it out to
Ice Station zebra associates Ice Station
zebra associates is one of many winks
that the eventual better call Saul
spin-off took from this shot like
mentions nacho Lalo and even a hint at
Jimmy's actual name look I'm only going
to say this once because it's not really
about this show exactly and I already
feel strange about doing it but the way
Breaking Bad has spun this episode and
character into another show full of
immense humor and depth may be the
greatest magic trick the TV double in a
place after that we can discuss Visa or
MasterCard but definitely not American
Express so don't even ask
it's almost addictive never leaving home
without it you're gonna give me off
right high school girlfriend Joe and
advertently inspire cinemasins to create
college girlfriend jokes and then write
them long after they've run DRA exactly
like my cup public drinking fountains
discussing my client unseen here but
seriously how does all have a clue
they're discussing his client and how
does Hank know who saw was talking about
both times they had him dead to rights
Joe and then poof look the show has some
of the most amazing writing of any
television show ever but it over uses
the word yo to the point that I want to
stick pencils in both my ears you know
kids your nephew is gonna get out in no
time
that's wonderful shadowing I've been
told that one of them killed another man
by crushing his head with an ATM machine
it is not a PIN number it is not the HIV
virus it isn't a UPC code or an LCD
display and it's not a goddamn ATM
machine we've done that acronym syndrome
is a real problem and it must stop now
and Ras syndrome today God you are
killing me with that booty it's all
apparently went to the Michael Scott
School of officing things I don't take
bribes from strangers you better safe
than sorry that's my motto I thought
your motto is better call Saul you only
get one motto Saul here's a sin for
being a greedy bastard and wanting to
mix your mottos not shanky cousin huh if
you're trying to avoid detection I'm
guessing the best way is to not be
driving the wrong way down an obvious
one-way street but hey that's just me
Jamie fake Heisenberg drops to his knees
as if he already knows he's being
arrested if his primary job is to be
convincingly arrested for crimes he
didn't commit he needs to work on his
crap I haven't seen someone drop to
their knees unprovoked that quickly
since my college girlfriend met my
college roommate this pen has teleported
from here to here I'm telling you
Breaking Bad is obviously a sci-fi show
and no amount of explaining will
convince me otherwise if I can find you
how far behind can the cops be Jimmy
McGill was right the hardest thing this
show asked us to swallow is that Walter
would get away with any of this
undetected and that it would take his
brother-in-law in-law anytime to put the
pieces together it's a fun impossibility
for sure but an impossibility
nonetheless
in dirt no me oh come on I was joking
come on
don't walk away angry son come on I mean
what are you complaining about you got
abs man kinda let me be blunt man I
liked you better when you were Silent
Bob public masturbation what I'll get it
what's the kick why don't you do it at
home like the rest of us with a big
flat-screen TV what is wrong with you
people
ah you want a criminal lawyer or I'm
saying well I'm awake and I speak
English so yeah I do know what you're
saying
i-i've been told that that one of them
killed another man by crushing his head
with an ATM machine enticing your head